the david pakman show subreddit at david
pakman.com slash reddit has surpassed
15,000 viewers and listeners some
interesting posts i spotted on the
subreddit this morning David Pakman is
bad
for the left movement in general says
user rmx 245 David does have some good
points every now and then but he really
comes off as MSNBC Lite he tried to make
it seem like Bernie and Warren had no
difference only someone who is trying to
Gaslight people in general would make
this claim um I I hate to tell you but I
have multiple segments about how Bernie
and Warren are not the same and in fact
I almost have been to a fault
going out of my way to issue disclaimers
every time this comes up so that I am
NOT misunderstood as suggesting that
Warren and Bernie are the same and the
last two weeks I've been going EE out of
my way to explain that so this is either
someone who is misinformed or someone
making a bad faith argument but because
they are making it I guess in a
respectful way it is fine for others to
respond to them on the subreddit that's
the type of engagement that you can
participate in at david pakman.com slash
read it another quite a few posts
actually noting that the twitch stream
of the debates with my commentary on
tuesday evening went down and a lot of
confusion as to what happened and indeed
twitch took down my live stream of the
debate and commentary they took down sam
cedars as well which was on twitch I
heard that Sam switched over to Vimeo we
do it on YouTube and get shut down so we
switched to twitch that got shut down
and Sam then going to Vimeo I guess
which is like kind of tier three option
I didn't do that I just ended up going
to bed but we are thinking about what to
do for subsequent debates
it seems mostly at CNN that aggressively
enforces copyright in this way at least
for now we've not had the problems with
other networks but you know who knows
what will happen at the November debate
but I will keep you apprised as to if
and where I will be streaming commentary
producer Pat Forde is going to be taking
over as host of not if the david pakman
show just of the Friday bonus show okay
Pat did such a great job when I was out
for my emergency appendectomy that
people wrote in saying you know you
should just let Pat host the bonus show
every once in awhile and we're gonna do
that on Fridays but Pat wants to hear
from you what do you want him doing on
the bonus show what do you want him
talking about on the bonus show do you
have questions for Pat that you want him
to answer on the bonus show so if you go
to our subreddit right now david
pakman.com slash read it you will see
sticky at the top a post called
i'm producer pat ask me anything you can
post your questions or topic ideas for
pat on the friday bonus show in that
thread subscribe to the subreddit takes
a second it's a great place for
political discussion david pakman.com
slash read it